Of course, there are situations or life events that can bring on a depressive
episode. But for some people, depression just seems to come on without an
external event. So, here we can see the interplay between our Neurochemistry
and our life circumstances. For example, people who are deficient in the
neurotransmitters seratonin and neuropeptide Y, are more likely to experience
depression following an extremely stressful event. Therefore, we can have two
people face the same stressful event and only the person who's deficient in
serotonin and neuropeptide y will actually result in depression. So, here we
see the environment or nurture which is the stressful event and the
neurochemistry or nature, the lack of serotonin and neuropeptide Y and the
resulting depression.